[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta edición de enlace
Centroamérica desde Panamá hoy
hablaremos sobre el bosque barrocolorado
un centro que recibe al año a unos 1.200
científicos de al menos 50
nacionalidades para ser investigaciones
sobre la naturaleza se trata de una isla
de 15 kilómetros cuadrados que se formó
hace más de 100 años en plena vía del
canal de Panamá
la preocupación por utilizar parte de la
selva para la ruta trans oceánica yegua
naturalistas de la época promover un
espacio protegido para su estudio debido
a Su riqueza en flora y fauna y además
por estar ubicado en medio de dos
océanos
barro Colorado fue la mayor Isla que
quedó formada Dentro de este lago
artificial en 1923 el lugar se declaró
como una reserva biológica y desde
entonces ha sido un instrumento para la
ciencia más de 23 mil investigaciones
científicas han salido de este
laboratorio vivo y se basan
fundamentalmente en el comportamiento de
las especies
la cifra de publicaciones de barro
Colorado casi llega a 23.000 muchos no
se conocían porque se habían publicado
en revistas
extranjeras que ya desaparecieron en
Europa en Asia entonces fue un trabajo
muy detallado que hizo la biblioteca Así
que en América Latina en el Caribe
realmente no hay nada que se compare con
la productividad
científica sobre los bosques tropicales
las plantas los insectos las aves como
barro Colorado Los investigadores se
hospedan en barro Colorado por tiempo
indefinido para hacer sus estudios son
lugar donde los científicos pueden venir
y estudiar el bosque
sin pensar que van a construir una
carretera Entonces se puede hacer
estudios de largo plazo que la vida en
el trópico es muy complejo y para
entender un sistema tan complejo de vida
necesita tiempo y necesito tiempo no
interrumpido desde estudios relacionados
con el efecto que puede tener en el
ambiente el calentamiento del suelo un
censo de vegetación la visión nocturna
de algunas abejas y el monitoreo para
conocer el comportamiento de los monos
además de grabar el sonido que emiten
los murciélagos son parte de algunas de
las 400 investigaciones que se realizan
en este momento en la isla barro
Colorado desde hace poco menos de una
década Andrew Investiga el efecto de los
suelos calientes en el medio ambiente
desde la zona donde realiza sus pruebas
y apoyan estudios hechos previamente en
el lugar hasta ahora su trabajo
demuestra la interacción que hay entre
las plantas y los microbios de los
suelos que reaccionan en forma más
agresiva con altas temperaturas en la
isla están trabajando mucha gente en
temas diferentes Entonces siempre hay
oportunidad para preparación con muchos
grupos trabajando con organismos
diferentes con plantas diferentes
con microbiólogo
trabajan con mitología y es como fuente
muy rico para desarrollar su
colaboraciones con otro científicos y
además con otro estudiantes Por otra
parte inga una científica alemana
aprovechando la gran diversidad de
murciélagos en el área hace sus
investigaciones con al menos 64 especies
normalmente trabaja con grabadoras para
recoger el sonido de estos animales
intenta comprender de qué forman los
sonidos son parte vital en la vida de
los mamíferos
durante la noche cuando está
completamente oscuro ellos sí pueden ver
pero no están usando
la visión están usando los sonidos que
emitan ellos y con esos se encuentran la
prensa se pueden manejar sobre el bosque
Y yo quiero saber
Cómo funciona ese sistema la
biodiversidad de La Isla barrocolorado
es muy rica según el instituto de
investigaciones tropicales Smith en el
lugar hay alrededor de 400 especies de
aves 500 especies de árboles y 2500
especies de insectos el caso de estos
últimos la cifra sigue en aumento
según Greg un entomólogo francés
radicado en Panamá en el mundo se conoce
uno punto dos millones de especies de
insectos pero se cree que son más de 8
millones los que pudieran existir
en esta parte del Trópico se ha dedicado
a trabajar con un equipo que desde 2008
evalúa el comportamiento de estos
pequeños animales en la isla y el
impacto en el cambio climático sin
factores adversos como pesticidas
deforestaciones o pérdida de hábitat es
más sencillo valorar el impacto de estas
especies en la vida humana necesitamos
de colectar haga a los insectos para
entenderlos la consecuencia de los
cambios climáticos sobre las
popupuración de insectos la dinámica de
la selva es exactamente relacionado con
los insectos Así que necesitamos de
entender lo que está pasando sobre la
subiendo de temperatura de la lluvia
etcétera etcétera según el entomólogo en
Lugares cercanos como Costa Rica o en
Estados Unidos y Europa es más difícil
este tipo de estudios por la disminución
considerable de la población de insectos
más de 40 años de monitoreo al ambiente
cerca de un siglo de datos climáticos
hacen de La Isla barrocolorado un lugar
para entender el medio ambiente la
evolución de los bosques tropicales Y
cómo sus habitantes cambian su
comportamiento Con el paso del tiempo
Gracias por acompañarnos en este enlace
Centroamérica desde Panamá soy Oscar
zuluarán y le invito a seguir con France
24 en español